the presidential recordings is a new
compilation of tapes and transcripts
from the first three months of lyndon
johnson's presidency
next hear clips and learn the context at
this talk from the lbj presidential
library and museum in austin texas it's
an hour 15 minutes
[Applause]
thank you very much
[Music]
the last uh
introduction
that effusive that i had
uh was by larry temple on the occasion
of my retirement and i
told the audience that uh i had written
it uh i
[Music]
i don't think i can say the same thing
for you but i do thank you very much
indeed
publication of the three volumes that
you see on the table up here tonight
represent
a significant uh
life day in the life of the lbj library
an important resource in the library's
collections is now in the process of
being made fully accessible four and two
scholarship
that resource is
of course the
many hours of president johnson's
telephone conversations which were
recorded during his administration
the library has been systematically
reviewing and opening that material and
it's a very very laborious process for
the past 12 years
80 percent of that material is now open
and
work continues on the remainder
as a federal archival depository
the
library makes available the original
material
in its holdings it does not itself
originate
origin material
so
to keep
as far as possible from coloring the
subject the library does not attempt to
make transcripts
of the material of the tapes
and that uh
under
less than expert hands that kind of
coloration can take place
there uh
there were transcripts occasionally made
in the white house by president
johnson's
secretaries
and one transcript in particular
uh
confused the archivists in the library
when they found it
it had president johnson
telling the person on the other end of
the telephone conversation that he would
have to cut off because he had a pack of
bastards waiting for him waiting to see
a careful uh
listening to the tape showed that what
he said was he had the pack ambassador
waiting for it
so if the transcripts are to serve
history they have to be scrupulously
accurate
and that kind of transcribing
as laborious and it is as laborious and
as critical as the processing of the
tapes themselves
and that kind of transcribing is being
taken over by the miller center
the miller center is devoted to the
study of the modern presidency in the
university of virginia
and it has
as these volumes
demonstrate taken on that very
substantial and important task
as part of a larger project the center
plans to transcribe every one of lbj's
conversations
the director of the presidential
recordings program and one of the
general editors of the series
in discussion tonight
is timothy naftali i'm pleased to
introduce him to you mr naftali
[Music]
well thank you harry you really can't
retire you've got a lot to read
it's a privilege for us
from the
university of virginia's miller center
public affairs to be able to launch our
lbj publication series in your company
and that of the johnson family and the
johnson community of france
in doing our work we are ever mindful
that lyndon baines johnson was a husband
and a father
as well as a president
and the johnson family's decision to
open this treasure treasure trove must
not have been easy
given that hearing the voice of a
departed loved one
is not
easy
therefore we scholars can never
adequately express our gratitude to you
harry and the johnson family for these
historical materials
i'd also like to try to thank betty sue
flowers and the lbj library and the lgbj
foundation and the national archives for
making us feel so at home here in austin
we at the presidential recordings
program are a relatively small team with
big ambitions
we envision that it will take 30 volumes
to capture all of president johnson's
telephone and meeting recordings as i
said henry harry you will have a lot of
reading to do
when we began this project we relied
almost exclusively on the generosity of
thomas jefferson's fans in albemarle
county virginia
as we broaden our work on lbj
we are building a national community of
supporters who are dedicated to seeing
that johnson's recordings are accessible
in transcribed annotated and digital
forms for the benefit of new generations
let me introduce the lbj editors who
worked so hard on the volumes we're
celebrating tonight
there are also two editors
who are not volume editors but made a
substantial contribution
uh who were in the audience and i would
like to recognize both pat dunn our
assistant editor
and also ashley high our associate
editor for having done so much to make
these volumes possible there is a fourth
editor max holland who unfortunately
could not attend and be with us tonight
well the three scholars in front of you
are very talented men
kent germany and he's the first you'll
hear from is the chief of the lbj
project a graduate of tulane and an
assistant professor at the university of
virginia kent is completing a new book
entitled the end of dixie a history of
liberalism and southern culture
1964-1974
besides being the proud father of three
girls kent finds time to guest host for
the record a pbs public affairs talk
show
but kent wanted me to make clear to all
of you that he spent the five most
formative years of his childhood
living in rural east texas
[Music]
always a texan david tree is both the
second volume editor and the second
louisianan here with us tonight
an lsu grad in u.s economic history and
also an assistant professor at the
miller center david has worked on both
our kennedy and johnson books having
spent three years as a budget analyst in
the louisiana house of representatives
david understands very well creative
accounting
and has seen firsthand
how skilled legislators can fund their
own pet project
his forthcoming book is on the genius of
a great legislator who is dear to all of
our hearts and who managed to get his
national programs funded that book will
be lbj and the promise of american life
the political economy of the great
society
robert david johnson whom we know as kc
was my classmate at harvard where he
earned his phd in
casey is a professor of history at
brooklyn college and currently is a
visiting professor at harvard
once at harvard well whatever
a prolific writer
casey wrote or has written among other
books the celebrated the peace
progressives and american foreign
relations
his new book congress and the cold war
will be out in december
casey has no southern or texas ties
other than his admiration for lyndon b
johnson
and frankly that should be good enough
before my colleagues play some marvelous
selections from the tapes tonight
by the way you know that we're
celebrating two people tonight we're
celebrating harry but we're also going
to celebrate president johnson and i
think he'll like the fact that you'll
hear more from him
than from anybody else tonight
but before we move on to the selections
from the tapes
i'd like to ask harry to tell us
something of how it is that this bounty
came to be made available to all of us
thank you
well i think
i think this story is known to a good
many people
here in the auditorium but i'll be glad
to uh to to go over it um
soon after president johnson died
a woman who had worked for him in a
confidential capacity for many years
mildred stegall she may be here tonight
mildred are you here
one of the
great figures out of the johnson years
she uh she came to me and
said that she had in her possession
seven record center
cartons
containing
belts of conversations recorded
conversations that had been secretly
made in the white house by president
johnson
they
had been left to her she said they've
been given to her by president johnson
with instructions that if they were
still in her possession at the time he
died she should turn them over to me
with instructions that they be kept
closed for a period of 50 years after
his death
i accepted them on that basis
and
and we immediately began to
go about the task of making sure that
they were preserved we opened the boxes
and found that they were dictables that
were all crammed together and
rather than run the risk of of having
those belts turned to dust in the 50
years
we
re-boxed them and
so that they would be
preserved
i
began however to
to
get the idea that i really wanted to
open those tapes i didn't know what was
in them
uh
i did not know they existed some of my
colleagues
did know that uh there were
tapes had been made but i did not know
that
and i certainly did not know what was in
them but i was certain that they were
going to be
important historical materials
and it seemed to me that they would be
far
better
to serve history if they were open now
then 50 years after
the president's death
i didn't immediately act on it but i
began to to
take some steps
and i so i consulted a couple of lawyers
one was larry temple here and uh another
was the uh the council for uh national
archives to make sure that i was not if
i decided go ahead and open them that
i would not be violating
any law and the answer was for both that
there was no reason to think that there
would be any violation of a law
and so the next step was to talk to
ladybird johnson uh she had no
responsibility for them at all the
president did not leave them to her she
was not in the loop
he uh he had left his everything that
he had left he left directly to the
government
uh
but i thought there was a possibility
that there would be
some
um
flack
from this i i thought there
it was most likely that there would
there would be some adverse reaction and
if there was i really wanted
her to be
on my side
and i decided that if she did not
acquiesce i i um
i wouldn't do it
but i had the marvelous opportunity of
talking to her about it um
in acapulco uh uh one of the uh great
perks of the job betty sue i'm sorry
you're not going to get it because she's
too old now but
uh was to spend uh a week with her my
wife and i did a week with her every
winter in acapulco
and mrs johnson had this uh and probably
still does
uh
this
feeling that she has to
actually work
for every bit of pleasure she has she
can't really enjoy anything unless she
feels that she has earned it by a little
bit of work so i decided i would give
her some work and uh i uh on
one occasion
told her about these tapes she did not
know about them she had no idea they
existed she didn't know what was in them
but i told her all about it i gave her a
briefed her on the whole thing and i
told her i really wanted to open them in
spite of the president's uh
instructions presumably from the grave
that they should be kept closed
and i
i
told her why and
she
she has a marvelous sense of history
herself
and she could understand that they were
going to be important historical
materials
and
she could see why it would be
better to
open them now than to wait
that isn't to say that she found it easy
because she she was
aware of the fact that uh her husband
had uh
uh
given these instructions nonetheless
she said and i want to tell you i i
think she is one of the gutsiest ladies
i've ever known in in in a good many
ways
and uh knowing all the risks that might
be involved she said
she would support whatever decision i
made
and so it was easy from that time on to
make the decision and consequently
that is
that that is the beginning of it it was
made somewhat easier in a sense because
right after that the congress mandated
that
that every
archival depository that had anything at
all relating to the kennedy
assassination should
open
that material
no matter how
classified it was
and uh so we made the decision here
without having read listen to any of the
tapes we made the decision that
uh everything that first month was going
to relate in some way or other to the uh
kennedy assassination so we opened all
of that material first and then from
there on it was it was relatively simple
once the decisions been made to begin to
open the rest of it so um
that is the story i'm very pleased that
we did it i i think it uh
i i i do
look back on it as uh one of the
probably the thing that i'm proudest of
in the 30 years that i was director of
the library but i also want to say that
uh
every time i even think of taking a bow
for it i
reserve i take half a bow and i reserve
the other half for lady bird johnson
thank you
[Applause]
oh and now i it is my
uh
my pleasure to begin the
operation that will uh
uh show some of the uh
uh
to some of the tapes and i think we
begin
with kent germany
some of the heaviest moments in american
history are those that uh
the death of president john kennedy
and
mr germany has the recording of how that
traumatic moment was transmitted to
kennedy's staff
thank you director middleton and
i certainly want to echo the thanks that
everyone has given you today uh and
certainly to the johnson family
because if it weren't for you it may be
unemployed
and as johnson said you know people
shouldn't live off the dole
so i guess i'm living off the johnson
dole
at some level
unfortunately max holland could not be
here tonight we were fortunate enough to
have max as the editor of volume one of
this three volume series max has a very
deep knowledge about the assassination i
believe he came and gave a talk here at
the lbj library
so i don't want you to confuse me i'm
not max i'm kent but i'm going to fill
in and play a clip that comes from his
volume
and the volume that max worked on
essentially doesn't start with the
assassination of john kennedy but it
starts with a couple of airplanes
that were in the air and bouncing around
the country and one of those planes was
carrying just about half of the cabinet
it was about two hours west of honolulu
when they got some transmissions that
something funny had happened in dallas
and some reports
that the president that president
kennedy had been shot
and what i want to play here
is a clip
of how
the president's press secretary and how
the secretary of state were receiving
information about events on the ground
in dallas this first clip is about um
they're receiving word that president
kennedy had been shot
this is white side you read me over
this is the situation room i read you go
ahead
give me all available information on
president over
all available information on president
follows
uh
john he and
governor connolly of texas have been hit
in the car in which they were writing we
do not know how serious the situation is
we have no information
mr bromley smith is back here in the
situation room now we are getting our
information over the tickers over
uh that is affirmative
[Applause]
keep us affirmative
on here this plane on which uh secretary
of state other cabinet ministers headed
for japan
turning around returning to honolulu
will arrive there approximately two
hours
[Applause]
over you have anything else wayside so
any other information
is possible all right the uh associated
press is coming out now the bulletin to
the effect that they believe the
president was hit in the head that just
came in over final
[Applause]
roger
we will pass on any additional
information we get from here to you
i understand uh this is
hold on the line there wayside we have
some more information coming up
[Applause]
uh way sideways this is a situation room
i read
uh from the ap bulletin kennedy
apparently shot in head he fell face
down in back seat of his car
blood was on his head mrs kennedy cried
oh no and tried to hold up his head
connolly remained half seated slumped to
the left there was blood on his face and
forehead
the president and the governor were
rushed to parkland hospital near the
dallas trademark
where kennedy was to have made a speech
over
that over
uh this is situation room i have nothing
further for you now
i will contact you if we get more
[Applause]
a few minutes after this call was at 12
45 this was a radio transmission at 12
45 pm a few minutes after this president
kennedy would be declared dead
officially
to the press at 1 30 and then word went
out to the plane carrying half the
cabinet over the pacific informing them
of the condition of the united states
government
all right roger i have crown on would
you give me a call sir
[Applause]
uh
this is situation room uh relay
following to wayside
we have report quoting mr kilduff in
dallas that the president is dead
that he died about 35 minutes ago
do you have that over
here
that is correct
that is correct
new subject
front office desires plane return
washington with no stop dallas overcome
and uh
[Applause]
this is situation room out
president johnson faced some monumental
decisions
after the death of president kennedy
but the immediate decisions that had to
be made were fairly simple first of all
you turn the plane carrying half the
cabinet around you have them go back to
washington dc you load up air force one
you go back to the nation's capital and
you begin governing
and lyndon johnson stepped off the plane
and asked for help from two key
constituencies
one of them the american people and the
other one was god
and with that lyndon johnson
became president
for the american people
and at that point
he decided uh to move forward with the
kennedy legacy and to push forward with
the legislative agenda that the kennedy
administration had put in place
as part of this he began reaching out to
world leaders to political leaders to
family members to mothers to wives
and
this was the beginning of the lyndon
johnson era in american politics
david shreve is going to
introduce two clips about johnson and
his drive for economy in his attempt to
cut the budget
while doing things for people
thanks kat um
and i i guess it's a little more than
that in that um
one of the uh
reviewers of uh the first three volumes
uh suggested
oddly in his review at one point
after citing
a couple of the conversations about
economic policy
concluding that this just suggests that
president johnson was willing to change
with the wind
i came across a similar sentiment
when i looked through the papers of t
harry williams
a former lsu professor who
late in his career uh set out to write a
biography of lyndon johnson and sadly he
died in 1979 before he could get the
work underway but i went back and wanted
to see if there was anything
that he had already formed worth reading
and uh having admired his work on his
pulitzer prize winning work on uep long
i thought that there might be something
there
and in this area too he he drew a
similar conclusion he said perhaps in
one of his notes to himself that
the president did not have a coherent or
well-formed approach to economic policy
or ideology
and i've i've come to think that nothing
could be further from the truth
um and uh i chose a couple of these
clips because they give you a glimpse
of uh of that approach and that ideology
now mind you these are just two
conversations out of many and and one of
the virtues of this uh collection
is that
uh you don't just see the highlights and
you don't just see president you know
the president interacting with one or
two people here and there even
chief chief policymakers in his cabinet
or uh in the congress
but you see many phases of his mind at
work and many different operations uh
simultaneously
and that's true for even one category
like economic policy
but what these two conversations show us
i think is a glimpse
of the
ways in which he
had to deal
with
policy the making of economic policy the
kinds of opposition that he faced and
the first one you'll
hear him uh in a sense pleading with
walter hiller the chairman of his
council of economic advisers
to consider him
as a new dealer
a democrat liberal democrat uh and
part of the problem he faced i think
early on was that
many in that crowd
didn't trust him in that regard or
didn't think that he was
faithful enough and and he wants to show
heller or tell heller that uh that that
he is faith faithful to this this kind
of an ideology he begins to explain it
here
walter heller was a minnesotan a close
friend of hubert humphrey he also worked
for the roosevelt administration
during world war ii in the department of
the treasury so he and johnson had that
in common as former new dealers
but he was chosen by president kennedy
of course to be his chairman first
chairman of the council of economic
advisers johnson inherits him at this
point
and uh this first conversation
conversation
comes at a time when professor heller
is beginning to go on a number of tv
shows and
undertake a number of interviews with
prominent journalists about the johnson
economic policy so let's uh let's listen
i'm in he's been from since the day it
was first announced he participated in
the formulation of the bill and he said
he made all the meat
he's made speeches all over the country
about it perhaps more than anybody in
administration he's no johnny come
lately
right to it now uh
why is he cutting these expenses he's
cutting the waste and the
the uh things that he need not to in
order he has some money to do the things
that he doesn't need to do and
he may take out the antiquated
installation where they're teaching
somebody to fly a plane that'll never be
flown that will they need a missile
instead in order to help grandma or
somebody in west virginia tennessee
that's not eating down right next
between an installation and uh
he's for grandma
yeah that's that's uh that's very good
and of course that follows the theme on
that today show also which uh used that
that kind of an illustration i've never
agreed that you had to prove your
liberal by showing how much money you
could throw away
i have always supported
wpa and pwa and river development
resource development and full
utilization and public housing
everything else right i never i never
supported corruption and
any of those things i never supported
waste in any of them and i never
supported it
just
throwing away common sense and operating
them i believe and
uh i'm a kind of a hero take his level
well and uh of course uh you know paul
douglas has done a lot of work to make
economy and government respectable and
uh
the greatest liberals we got box fire
they don't believe throwing money away
yeah right
you don't know whether either one would
like to be compared to the other or not
but
strange pattern in that regard or as
you're concerned i've been this is no
johnny cup lately i on the naval affairs
committee in 1938 i was running an
investigation pointing up wasting the
navy in 1948 i was pointed up in the
senate as head of the preparedness
committee and i've done this this stuff
for 12 15 years
in the senate right i've had 25 years
pointing up waste that's all i'm doing
in the federal government but that
doesn't mean that
we're not going to have a national
science foundation that doesn't mean
he's not going to have an appalachian
program and that doesn't mean that we're
not going to have a better program for
the peace corps
uh what it does mean is we're going to
have less money wasted and more money
available for those things because of
the stopping the weight right well that
that's exactly uh
something i want to stress and maybe
maybe
thirsty people
but that doesn't mean that you ought to
turn on a hundred and let the tank all
run drunk before you put a bucket under
what we're doing is we're gonna we're
gonna put a bucket under it and save all
we can
all right
uh tonight
in this connection of course there's an
awful lot then especially because of
galbraith speech which by the way i
asked him to send you a copy of he said
he would today
uh
does that uh if they ask about poverty i
think that one can say that we're
working on uh such a program now the
question is investigative speech with a
great deal of interest and i've already
asked him to send a copy of it and
expect to be talking to him about
about the next few days i'm very
interested in that program and i believe
in a government uh
people
right pwp right
okay very good you tell me that i was
very excited about the newspaper reports
i'm surprised he didn't have me a copy
autographed over here but he's my hero
and i want him to get it to me right
away i'll do just that
right out thank you
i i failed to explain that
the the
the first item to which he refers there
is the
the tax cut proposal and you may have
guessed that by by reading this and of
course there's a general reference to
his uh
attempt to uh to cut the budget
um you find out in this conversation
a little bit more about why he
melted such a crusade
there are many reasons for it some of
which you just learned about in in this
conversation
but admittedly it becomes clear as you
listen to a series of these
conversations around this this time
that that part of the effort is designed
to be political and cosmetic as well
and uh one
hurdle for the the tax cut that had been
proposed first in the kennedy
administration and that johnson had
taken up
was the
chairman of the senate finance committee
harry byrd and you'll see a reference to
mr byrd in this conversation
you also hear president johnson make a
reference to a man by the name of tom
gerdler
some of you may remember tom gerdler
relatively obscure these days but
he was
referred to in a famous 1940 speech
delivered by fdr uh and his name was
used as a synonym for enemy of the
people
this was the manager of republic steel
most
responsible for the
1937 memorial day massacre
yet at the same time
this was a guy who later on went to be
the general manager of uh consolidated
volte aircraft corporation during world
war ii otherwise known as convair and
became something of a hero to the
american people so
you can read between the lines here and
you can see what what president johnson
is saying to heller in this conversation
is when he says we have to please tom
gerdler that we have to make this
program palatable and pleasing to people
like that that you you really probably
don't like very much but are at the same
time held in high regard by a great
number of americans
so you get that and you get a little
taste for his approach to to passing the
tax cut here in this conversation again
with uh with walter heller chairman of
the council of economic advisors
so uh i want you to look at that and
talk to treasury i'm going to have to
get my estimates up here and i don't
want to be
too low on my estimates on what we're
going to do with these receipts if we
get a tax bill yeah well i think that
i'd rather i'd rather be on the high
side like every president has from
hoover i'd rather say they're going to
be 94 and have 93 than say they're 92
and i have 93
right i agree you talk to treasury and
see what your estimates look like and i
want this deficit just as low as i can
and my estimate is the news story
and i don't mind being a little
optimistic hell i'm an optimist by
nature well i you know i don't want to
be too much of an exaggerator but i sure
want to be optimistic and i want to
assume that things are going well and i
believe they are and i believe business
is
pretty safe in this country and labor
too and well i just but but let me just
i don't think i invited you they invite
you to the state of the union thing
today yes they did they sure want you to
get up right good sharp
imaginative stuff now they tell me
poverty has got to go out because you
all haven't gotten a good program oh no
you got it you've got to hear us out i'm
not going to do it unless you've got
something that that'll satisfy tom
gurdley we're going to want something to
stand up we're gonna discuss it with ted
uh right now well what are you what are
you gonna report what are you gonna do
what's what's substance what how
i don't want any of these uh any of
these boondoggles now well that's what
they're looking for well i'm sure they
are an old nya man and i i had the best
record of any administrator in the
nation according to aubry williams but
he fussed with me because i put a little
steel and some statewide roadside parks
but i've got 4 600 of them down there
that's right they're still lasting and i
got a dollar to show for every dollar i
spent and i had uh ninety percent of it
was labor ten percent of material but
somebody's gotta find projects of that
type i'm not gonna spend it out here now
on
where it's all going for steel or where
it's all just going down the drain and
having some
well as a matter of fact the criticism
more than anything else i think has been
that we haven't put enough of it into
brick and mortar what we're trying to do
is put it into people that's good well
that's what i'm for and how are you
doing it to lloyd lieberman well we're
doing it through uh the uh the education
uh health programs uh and and
incidentally trying to bring the states
and localities in it so that they do
their share that's good all right okay
you go and get me a good solid program
and harry bird will look upon with
pleasure and i'll approve it for you you
say to get tough stand here
well there you go i think
i i agree wholeheartedly with uh joe
califano who said on a number of
occasions that uh
this was about revolution really this
was about changing the way we ran our
economy in a lot of different ways
and uh this just gives you a little
glimpse of how how rough that that was
at the outset and and i think it
remained difficult even at the at the
very end of the administration so you'll
um you know perhaps be able to hear in
the future other conversations in 1966
and 67 and 68
in a different vein but
about the same general subject
now i believe the next selection is
going to be a foreign affairs selection
and
i think casey johnson is going to set
those up for us casey
thank you all for coming thank you for
inviting me here uh in the years
following world war ii uh the congress's
power over foreign affairs as
traditionally exercised through the
power to declare war or in the senate's
case to approve uh treaties by and large
declined
but in one area
in foreign policy the the new foreign
aid program uh congress's power was very
much present because foreign aid was an
appropriations program it had to be
passed by congress there was extensive
congressional involvement uh throughout
uh presidents from the inception of the
foreign aid program struggled to get
foreign aid through an economy-minded
congress there wasn't a constituency or
much of a constituency for foreign aid
in the united states uh and in the 1950s
uh presidents began to have a particular
problem
with this uh after the house reorganized
created a new subcommittee called the
foreign operations subcommittee and
named as the chair of this subcommittee
a louisiana congressman named otto
passman a figure who the columnist evans
and novak dubbed the shrill shopkeeper
from shreveport uh
passman was was uh
someone who believed in cutting the
foreign aid program uh to the bone and
then some uh who had extensive knowledge
of the program was a very very difficult
person uh to deal with uh dwight
eisenhower in 1957 after password was
invited to the white house told his
chief of staff to make sure that passman
never again received a white house
invitation during eisenhower's tenure as
president uh john kennedy went through
two uh directors of foreign aid
the second david bell had to be
arm-twisted
to take the position because he said he
didn't want to have to deal with otto
passman on a day-to-day uh basis passman
had uh an unusual habit of calling
people in for friday or saturday uh
committee hearings uh forcing them to
return from overseas trips and then
canceling the uh the hearings at the
last minute uh lyndon johnson expected
that he would be able to deal with
passman more effectively than had his uh
predecessors uh partially because of his
success in dealing with
other conservative southern democrats
like harry byrd as we sort of got a clip
of
in the last call
johnson invited passman in a
high-profile meeting to the white house
in december of 1963 he informed the
congressman that he would be rigorous in
terms of supporting uh cuts in foreign
aid and elimination of waste
thought that he had a deal worked out
with passman only to find passman renege
on this uh deal push through a dramatic
cut in the foreign aid appropriation for
1963
partially by
a successful appeal on pacman's part to
a number of conservative texas democrats
whose votes johnson thought he had uh
commitments from but it turned out he
did not uh and this is a conversation a
clip of a short conversation between uh
the president and texas congressman jack
brooks on the night after the house had
pushed through the passman sponsored
cuts
you don't know honestly how i feel
i'm really humiliated that i'm president
i got a friendly speaker
and i got a friendly majority leader
i got a friendly albert thomas i got a
friendly jack brooks
and octopus one is king
i think that's disgraceful in this
country because i won't tell you when i
see you the next time confidentially
what are we looking at in the world it's
a hell of a lot worse than was last year
and you're giving us three billion
people and you gave kennedy three nine
and i don't think that's fair and i
don't think it's right i think it's
awful at a goddamn
cajun from the hill to louisiana
it's got more power
got more power than all of us i just
think that's awful but that's what you
got to do and someday we'll get our way
and if i ever walk up in the cold
tonight and rattle snakes out there and
about ready to get him i ain't going to
pull him off i'll tell you that
you remember that i want you to remember
we got some people who i remembered and
you just you just go and tell all these
texans that want to hit russia and i
want to put those sons of [ __ ] in
uniform they let them go go go fight the
communists for a while they like to talk
a big game but they don't want to do a
damn thing about it i'm with you okay
good night bless your heart
uh in in addition to to appropriations
cuts that forced a reorientation of the
foreign aid program the the other way
that congress tended to exercise
influence using the foreign aid was by
attaching policy related riders
amendments to the foreign aid uh budget
that technically had nothing to do
specifically with foreign aid but
affected broader foreign policy concerns
and this was a real problem uh in the
1963 foreign aid bill a session that
came to be known as the foreign aid
revolt uh where the kennedy
administration essentially lost control
of the legislative situation in the
senate and a variety of these
policy-related amendments got tacked on
to the 63 uh foreign aid bill
johnson again thought he would be able
to manage this more effectively but on
the same day that the house passed the
measure that cut the appropriations it
also passed an amendment sponsored by an
illinois republican congressman named
paul finley
dealing with a request that had come
from the soviet premier nikita
khrushchev to increase grain shipments
from the united states to the soviet
union there was a a wheat famine uh in
the soviet union in 1963.
the the finley amendment was was a
demagoguery amendment it required uh if
additional uh shipments of grain were to
go to the soviet union that the
president had to make a public
certification that this shipment uh
served the national interests of the
united states it was an attempt
essentially uh to get the democratic
president on record as appearing to be
uh pro uh soviet johnson had a quite
clear recognition of what finley's
intent uh was and in this conversation
between johnson and another texas uh
congressman albert thomas uh the
president is lamenting the uh political
and legislative effects of the passage
of this amendment
ambition now
well no no of course not
but i don't think it's gonna i don't
think it's gonna hamstring you fit on
there it doesn't have a string it just
publicizes that i'm pro-russian right
when nixon's running against me
that's all it does well he ain't gonna
run because he ain't
[Music]
you and our buddies now and you
understand politics and i do too and i'm
telling you that we're working with the
republicans up there one hundred percent
well i'm on yourself well all right well
you just don't ever agree that that's a
good clause because you know god damn
well it ain't don't try to [ __ ] me cause
i know better yes it's big well i've
worked with it in the space yeah you
work with it but you've been working
with it under republican presidents not
on the democrat when a democratic
president has to report that he makes a
determination that's in his interest to
go with russia it's not good when you
run involved now you know that
don't you
ultimately the the president succeeded
in in half on this measure he got the
finley amendment excised in in the
conference committee although he was not
able to restore the appropriations cuts
that uh passman had uh pushed through
in foreign policy as a whole uh johnson
by and large retained the team at least
initially that he had inherited from
president kennedy with one important
exception and that was with regards to
latin america uh johnson dismissed both
the assistant secretary of state for
latin american affairs and the head of
uh kennedy's alliance for progress uh
consolidated the positions and uh then
appointed uh thomas mann who had served
as assistant secretary of state in the
eisenhower administration as uh the new
uh coordinator of latin american policy
for uh the president mann had a
reputation as a conservative democrat
someone who was suspicious of the of
kennedy's foreign policy the alliance
for progress for what mansar is an
excessive
interest in promoting democracy in latin
america which he thought was unfeasible
in early january of 1964 man and johnson
would face their first foreign policy
tests in latin america after riots broke
out in panama in the canal zone when a
group of american high school students
the zoniacs
violated an agreement worked out between
the u.s and panama
that stated that
neither that high schools in panama
would fly both the american and the
panamanian flags but not just the
american flag these high school students
tore down the panamanian flag riots
ensued this seemed like it might uh
resolve itself uh very quickly as a
crisis but it did not the panamanian
presidential election was coming up
panamanians had an incentive to push for
a very hard line and the panamanian
president roberto chiari called for a
renegotiation of the panama canal
treaties as a precondition to resolving
uh this uh crisis and so this is a
conversation between uh johnson and uh
georgia senator dick russell to whom
johnson turned for advice about how to
handle the situation in panama this is a
conversation that occurs just after a
call between johnson and president
chiari that johnson had initiated one of
the more bizarre calls that i
encountered uh in the tapes it's a long
distance call uh johnson did not speak
spanish chiari did not speak english and
so there were translators and in the
middle of the call it was interrupted by
a long distance operator who ordered
johnson to get off the line because
there were other people who needed to
use the long distance line
uh
the the call ended with johnson uh
informing chiari that he would be
sending thomas mann down for a visit
and uh in this conversation we see
russell attempting to to push a strong
line uh in response
i was cold and hard and tough as hell so
far is exactly right so far as this is
concerned and i went back in and told
our group here
that uh i thought we had to remember
that a week ago two or three weeks ago i
had to tell them in bolivia i'd send
whatever aid i needed in there and make
them release one of our people there a
few days later a few days earlier they
had someone else locked up some other
place and i was damn tired of attacking
our flag and our embassy and our usis
every time somebody got a little
emotional outburst
they better watch it that's so i'm so
pleased now you you you that's a great
president that's man go down in history
now uh we i just want you to know that
and this group has gone and martin will
be coming back tomorrow but the old man
finally said well he's glad that he's
talking to a man that is taking some
action and i said well they'll be there
and
uh
i think science would be pretty tough
too well i felt a little mara down
there's a pretty good man well he's
he's had to order his people to start
shooting again yes well that's all right
they've got to be shooting at them you
can't expect how people stand there and
be killed not by a bank
well i i mean it's not anywhere in the
world i'm not trying to unjustify it or
just but i'm just saying
a mental state as far as we are
concerned
and uh
national image so far the united nations
is concerned and i think we can protect
both well i think the position that
ought to be on the hill is we ought to
be careful what we say but for god sakes
we say anything say we did right acting
properly to send some and the ableist
man we got down there now they tell me
that everybody in latin america uh
scared of this fellow man they highly
regard him because he's a tough guy he's
not the regular well i hope he is he's
much tougher than the ones we've had and
i i he he has a velvet glove but i hope
he has his little iron fingers under it
at least yeah i think he does i think he
does i'm counting on that
uh much much to the president's
disappointment what quickly developed in
the next 24 hours was that the crisis
got worse but also that the
administration itself divided uh and a
faction within the administration headed
by attorney general uh robert kennedy
and director of central intelligence
john mcconne argued that this crisis had
been blown out of proportion and that
the united states should essentially try
to appease it and end the crisis as
quickly as possible and so johnson
returns to russell uh the next day in an
attempt to sound out russell about how
congressional sentiment might respond to
a quick uh resolution of the crisis he
has a pretty good sense of what russell
is going to uh recommend as a result of
this this is a conversation that occurs
just before an nfc meeting to determine
how the administration should respond to
panama
why don't we just say why don't we just
say that
uh i concur in your recommendation that
you
uh
informed cherry that you will not now
agree to negotiation
and that
you'd be authorized to say this does not
close the door for all time
and you know
i wouldn't say make too old time it just
said it
that's what he says i'd say degrees of
negotiations under present condition but
we're not just does not close the door
all the time or fail that's a hell of a
long thing you send him down they would
confuse me if i were down there with all
the pressures that uh
he must feel
in that atmosphere down there he and
vance had a good talk with the fella and
both of them were awfully tough with him
and and this fellow every damn one of
them run against us for reelection 600
of them stood outside and said get out
of here gringos yeah they they've been
doing that they had they wanted to
announce the colossus of the north that
most both separately didn't want to win
that's been through the last three
elections they've had
on the status we haven't got a friend
now but if we wasn't there they wouldn't
have anything if he lived out there half
naked in no spawn
johnson does push a tough line on this
crisis and it will be several months
before it ultimately is resolved but
this i think is a good indication of
some of the latin american policy
differences between uh kennedy and
johnson dick russell was not an
important
policy or personal advisor on latin
american policy under kennedy in 1964 he
would emerge as a key adviser to uh to
johnson
and the last foreign policy related clip
is a conversation between johnson and
walker stone which offers an
illustration of one of the striking
things about the volumes as a whole i
think which is how complex a president's
day actually was that this is a
president uh and this is true for
johnson uh for kennedy and nixon as well
who had to go for through a variety of
issues very very quickly and so every
day would be dealing with 15 or 20
policy issues uh in these phone calls in
addition to a variety of personal uh uh
concerns uh foreign aid is on the uh
docket here between uh the president and
and uh walker stone uh but stone is is
speaking also on behalf of of old
friends of johnson who are concerned uh
this is a man who had a heart attack uh
just under a decade before that he might
be working himself a little bit uh too
hard and johnson's also very uh proud of
a letter that he's received from a man
that uh all of you know here jay frank
dobie that had come in uh in around two
weeks uh after he had acceded to power a
glowing letter uh saying that johnson
had successfully handled the transition
that johnson carried around with him for
several weeks in his pocket and would uh
flip it out at a moment's notice and and
read from it uh so this is a
conversation between johnson an old
friend discussing events uh in early
january of 1964.
all right were you listening for just a
minute
oh my god you asked for it
you're out facing
you're raising your motor
[Music]
you're
you are trying to do too much
i'm not you know what i've done i worked
on the budget
and i
i
don't know
but i'm like
you're trying to do too much
and and you're raising your motor
and and you're drinking too much and
you're not sleeping enough oh no
oh that's wrong i'll tell you what i'm
doing
uh
i had a quiet
morning i didn't come to the office
until i wake up 6 30 all my life i wake
up on a road gang and i can't get that
but you get up early don't you
you had to get through oklahoma you
can't tell me you ever made the big
leagues not getting up early it takes us
a little longer than better some other
folks and i get up early and i read all
the papers i read about 15 of them
when i read them in bed and i
relax drink my tea and
go to the bathroom and watch a
television
and then this morning i won't tell you
this stuff's got around town and my
friend's really worried i won't tell you
well i i never never enjoyed life more
never felt better in my life physically
than i do now at 12 45 today i took jack
valencia border checking
bill morgan
and i swam to like that through eight
times eight times today i went down had
a hamburger
i came back and looked over my state of
the union
called up busted the fellow about 40
million dollars too much in a budget
and stretched out took a little those
lost consciousness with about five
minutes on the couch
came back and they said now you're a
good younger said yeah well we'll save
you this didn't get in the bag i said
what is it
said it's george carmack's uh
article that we won't give it to you
when you're in the bathroom
well i knew it was going to be bad if
it's georgia and i read it and he said
that they always say that folks are not
true to their raising
but john smith is true to israel and he
wrote the kindest sweetest nicest
description i'm going to send it to dean
rusk mike george but then all he's
sophisticated colors
andrew bitter do you keep compliments
and your middle view
i want you to read it
and uh okay then i read old man dolby's
letter and
the funny thing was houston hart wrote
about like george carmack did for all of
his papers north american newspaper
alliance used it but he said if there's
ever a place where angela duke the
proper chief of protocol was not needed
it was don't walk
so i thought you would pay so i'm really
then i'm going over i'm going to bed
early you know i don't have anything to
do at night i can't go out if i i broke
out twice
what i do is i go home and i have myself
two three eyeballs my wife and i have to
sit there and read and work
i've got indonesia they wanted me to
give them 35 million the other day and i
had to read on it two o'clock in the
morning they came in and had to have
india 65 and i read on april 2 and
turned both up down but i just thought
what if i hadn't had the desire to read
them i'd be in a hell of a shape
now we'll be listening to some
conversations about johnson and texas
life with ken
casey
now that we've seen
lyndon johnson a day in the life of
lyndon johnson um
these in some ways are sort of america's
first reality show
we have 800 hours of it so if
if you can get this on abc
this will be endless entertainment for
the kids
these volumes
are
hopefully rich resources for scholars
and there are a lot of issues that
lyndon johnson as president deals with
in his first 71 days which are covered
in these first
since november 22nd through the end of
january
the war in poverty the budget
foreign aid
crises in panama in cyprus where there's
almost a civil war there's a coup in
vietnam uh there's constant turmoil in
africa a number of uh new governments
arise in coup d'etat in africa lyndon
johnson
is dealing with each of these as casey
has said on a daily basis and has to
deflect and
attract issues as he goes along during
the day
in the interim uh in the middle part of
this volume is christmas uh and lyndon
johnson and his family went home to
texas uh not far from uh where we're
sitting now and there are some very rich
conversations about what it's like to
live in texas
and i think for people who like to study
texas and study what it was like to
be a prominent person uh in texas some
people think lyndon johnson's now a
legend i'll let you decide whether you
think of that
he was certainly maybe the most
legendary talker
in american history
i'll have some arguments about that from
historians and other people
but what he has left us is 800 hours of
a legend talking and what passes through
the microphone
was lyndon johnson dealing with the
1960s in dealing with the many currents
that came across the desk of the
american president
but
on new year's day 1964 lyndon johnson
was less a president still dealing with
issues but less a president and more of
a family man and one who was touching
base with his old friends
and saying hello to people who met
who were dear to him and i want to play
a quick couple of clips here
this first one we don't have time to
play here but uh johnson is talking to
richard russell about a time that russia
came in apparently inebriated from a
football game and they said they put a
little brass plaque on the chair and
called it dick russell's chair the night
he came in uh with herman brown from the
football game uh
and as johnson would do in these
conversations handed the phone over uh
to his wife lady bird johnson and here
uh is an exchange between uh mrs johnson
the first lady and senator richard
russell
and by the way the backdrop i don't know
how many of y'all follow university of
texas longhorn football i suspect there
might be a few out there
as i grew up in texas but i grew up and
i'm going to say very quietly a texas a
m fan
and i'm heading out the back when this
is over
university of texas won the national
championship in collegiate football that
year and they beat navy in the cotton
bowl on january the first 1964.
many of you might remember navy's
quarterback uh a little fella named
roger stahlbach
university of texas won that game 24-6
and all of the calls that day to the
johnson ranch uh were glowing about
longhorn football and some of this comes
up uh in this clip and in the next one i
hope you have a wonderful new year and
wait a minute
aw won't speak behalf of man wesley and
a few of them here and say hi to this
girl talks to you all right sir
senator honey how are you
oh i'm fine
with great approval in the
newsroom
in the paper
there's nobody's approval that i want
more than yours
well all my love for you
yeah well
they were together with us at christmas
and we had all of lyndon's family at
christmas and now we're having my family
about 15 tailors
but my two children went with their
dates to watch the big ball game that
was a terrific ball game that texas
could be there and caught his team in
the world stay i never saw a team play
right there dude
and and then they'll be back tomorrow
and i want that lindenberg's gonna come
back up there the main reason she's
coming is because she wants to listen to
smart people like you and get smarter
and here's judge morrison
as as
professor naftali mentioned before i
spent much of my formative childhood in
rural texas
and as you do in rural texas you hear a
lot of stories
and you get used to listening to people
talk and this next conversation was
about something that also might be dear
to some people here it's about deer
hunting particularly down at the lbj
ranch between aw judge morrison a close
friend of the johnson family and again
uh richard russell this is a very long
conversation with richard russell and
we've split it up here in a couple
places
but this uh i could very well be sitting
at the general store in trinidad texas
hearing people talk about things this
way but this is a little slice of life
at the johnson ranch
there might be a little bit of bragging
here
and and here's judge morrison
hi senator yes how are you all right
happy new
i get along year fine you know the
london reminder that time i saw they
displayed myself over there and you had
to take care of it oh heck he said i
mentioned that he just kidding
how'd you like old texas today
but they just look like a high school
out there trying to play texas
they had a good team i don't tell you
that number 70 detectives was the most
terrific tackle i ever saw
in the line he was taking two or three
men out yeah he's tough you sure
he's not touching him
no he didn't determine
yeah he got speed and quicker
how are you feeling i'm feeling fine hey
i hope you are well you had a nice
holidays had a good time well that's so
funny
out there yeah we did we missed you well
i wish i could have been there
i hope the president didn't miss it many
times he did that time he treated that
shortage
no he made an awful good shot here he
shot he shot a beer i think about 350
yards right to his neck
well that one he really did you know i'm
not lying about that one
[Laughter]
well that's all right nobody ever killed
one as far as i put that in the homeless
shark though
it sure is good to hear you sound so
well that's good to have you here
so
the moral of the story is if you're at
the johnson ranch uh stay at least 351
yards away from president johnson
unless you have some tobacco and you're
feeding clearance
the last clip that we want to end with
today um is back more on on the
scholarly scene
in 1964 1965
the democratic party was at the height
of its power in post-world war ii
america it was the election in late 1964
that would provide the really the strong
electoral base and constituent base for
the passage of much of the great society
and it was lyndon johnson molding and
shaping the constituencies that provided
a good portion of that power
with the end of january 1964
lyndon johnson
is putting together a message that would
guide his campaign for the upcoming 1964
election
he had a conversation with
hubert humphrey who we all know
eventually would become the vice
presidential running mate and eventually
vice president at this time he was the
senate minority whip
johnson had heard him make a statement
about the democratic party earlier in
the day and thought it was fantastic so
he picked up the phone as he would do
and called him up to thank him and say
that's great but not to stop there to
say okay you've got the message out now
i want you to get all the other
democrats to get the message out and i
want you to get on television and i want
you to call the newspapers and i want
you to make sure that the american
people know that this isn't just one
thing you're saying we're going to keep
pushing this forward
this is the height of liberalism in
post-war america and lyndon johnson lays
out what he thinks first is good about
the democratic party but also what he
thinks is bad about the republican party
ironically on the other side of the
world at this time
a coup in south vietnam is beginning to
be set in motion which would undo a coup
that had occurred just prior to the
kennedy assassination
and
at this moment in late january 1964
which is where these volumes end
we have lyndon johnson expressing what's
really the bedrock
part of the democratic party's strength
and yet on the other side of the world
the complications in vietnam would
continue to fester
uh before i play this let me
cover a few things that people talk
about here roosevelt's boy jimmy there
were some
questionable financial transactions some
financial dealings that's what he's
talking about uh the dog fala there was
a story that uh franklin roosevelt
turned around an american destroyer to
go back to alaska to pick up his little
puppy
which was not a good use of american
money the truman and margaret the
margaret truman and harry truman bit
here harry truman reacted strongly to a
music critic's assessment of his
daughter's singing voice
and wrote a letter to
this man with the last name of hume and
said that uh if he ever saw him uh that
he would need a beefsteak for his eye
and a supporter below
he later when remembering what he wrote
had some different words that he chose
but those are a couple things that i
think would be helpful to get an
understanding of what's going on here
i'll just say well the reason the
republicans haven't won
any elections except eisenhower and i
didn't mess around to this trash he was
a national hero but the reason they have
won one one since hoover is because they
spent all the time on roosevelt's boy
jimmy and on his dog
and
uh they spent all their time on truman
and margaret and the music critics and
they spent all their time on
uh kennedy and
his religion and other things and they
just had one one and if they don't stand
for something hell if they just come out
here and talk about revival of
the corn tassel or gum come out for tom
watson watermelons it'd be something but
they just by got against things
against everything and trying to smear
in fear and that you have no alternative
mr sanders post dispatch man asked me
today said
what republican frightened you most i
said well not any of them now when one
of them comes out and said this is what
i stand for
and give me a foreign policy and said
here's what i'm for
and then he gave me a domestic policy
and said here's what i'm for here's what
i'm far in the field of education in the
field of manpower and field of training
and field civil rights then i'll get
scared because even if it's uh different
from mine they'll have a choice but now
they have any choice because we're the
only ones to stand for anything they're
just against things
just to say now damn it boys you get
here and get your speech and ask
questions here and get your name in the
paper here and every damn one of them
i'll take i'll take your line and what
we are
uh
uh we we're for war on poverty we're for
economic growth we're for world peace
we're for security we're for medicare
we're for human dignity we have a human
right now this is what we stand for a
government of strength a government to
solve it and the government is
compassionate
and it just makes these guys look silly
yes sir okay i just want to congratulate
you i was reading it there's the best
thing i've seen all day god damn it i
had indonesia and i had panama and i had
cyprus and they're coming in tonight 7
30 the british trying to shove us in
there overnight
and i guess we got to go but i'm trying
my damn just
get the turks to agree not to invade so
we can hold off another day or two so i
hope so well i just got back here after
we'd had a visit over there these press
boys were all waiting up here to see the
employees well you just let them have it
you just ought to hit it tomorrow just
every day you ought to say the
democratic party is one party left
america because the other fellows don't
stand fantastic i just uh god
pity them for they know not what to do i
just feel sorry for them because what do
they stand for
well
we're often
it takes a lot of patience to transcribe
but when you're transcribing someone as
colorful and interesting as johnson
it makes it all worthwhile
this is the first time that all of
johnson's tapes are being transcribed
michael bechtlas has done a wonderful
job of giving some of the greatest hits
to you
um but his work just covers seven
percent
of all the tran of all the conversations
for the first volume his volume for to
cover that period we're producing 11.
and the next three volumes of our set of
our series will be available a year from
now
we try to put as much as we can on the
web and eventually all of this will be
on the web so that anybody anywhere in
this country around the world can
download these tapes and transcripts
because we feel that this is the finest
way to teach people about civics and
citizenship
there is no better way to understand the
difficulties and obligations of being
the american president than sitting with
lyndon johnson as he tries to make this
a better world
we're very grateful that you came
tonight and i want to again thank harry
middleton for making this trove possible
with the help of the johnson family i
hope we're doing a good job and we could
use your help and we hope that this
material will be used
and
i think johnson i hope i can say that
lyndon johnson would be pleased if that
were the case
we have time for just a very few
questions if you have any uh there are
microphones on both aisles so if you do
have a question please step up to the
mic and if you are going to address it
to a particular person tell us who that
person is
um yes just to all of you up there it
seems like with that last clip this is a
good time to ask this question uh things
seem to have turned apparently the
democrat democratic party doesn't have a
message today i've been hearing that a
lot from the media in various sources
they do not have a message
what do you think the message should be
the miller center i should say is
officially a non-partisan organization
we are historians
maybe uh if we can channel lyndon
johnson's spirit and energy back
in live in american politics is that is
that safe to say
well
but the point is that parties that have
a positive message deserve to win
what i tell my students is the party
that controls those three issues of
strength solvency and compassion often
can control the middle ground in
american politics and i think that's
really part of the key
question over here
i applaud more than ever the decision
for the early release of the tapes
and
i certainly
feel that
understanding of politics and
how nations and decisions are made are
enormously facilitated by what is taking
place tonight
i ask a question
there are other presidential library
libraries
and i'm sure a lot of tapes
what's the possibility
of the early release
of some of the
information
contained
in various presidential libraries that
have followed lyndon johnson's thank you
um we are trying to transcribe um as
much of the
5 000 hours of presidential tapes as we
can the very first president of tape was
franklin roosevelt
the roosevelt truman and eisenhower
tapes are all fully available
the kennedy tapes are about 65 to 70
percent available
the johnson library deserves enormous
credit
for having moved faster
in the declassification of its tapes
than any other presidential library
there are um
still quite a few nixon tapes to be
released but the national archive system
which
faces budget constraints it's just all
of the government is doing its very best
to release the presidential tapes in
chronological order as quickly as
possible
frankly we haven't caught up with all
the tapes that the lbj library has
released thus far so
we want more tapes released the american
people deserve it but it's going to take
a while to transcribe them
larry wright
did i understand one of you say that
there was 800 hours of tape in total was
it
that's correct that just doesn't seem
like very many hours of tape and a
president's presidency spanned such a
long period of time and
and they were
if i understand it right there were
tapes on the phones
in the white house
at home uh in texas uh there were room
tapes and so it seems like
there should be more tape am i wrong
about that i i 800 hours
is a is a great treasure trove but it
seems like there would be thousands
that's all there were
and and with uh with with johnson uh too
he was unique in one regard with respect
to taping and tim of course just
mentioned the other presidents who have
have recordings
uh he was really the only one to use the
tapes it was a managerial tool and so
what i think you have is
we're fortunate in that early in the
administration
he had for whatever reason
the wherewithal to tape record and in
some cases to have white house
secretaries transcribe some of these
these recordings as well but as time
went on i think uh things just got a
little too hectic and uh to to make that
a high priority so that the number of of
tapes does drop off dramatically that
may in part explain why we only have 800
instead of 1500 or 2 000 hours which
uh if if he had gone at the same clip as
he had throughout 1964 that's what you
would have you would have that much
there is a phenomenal archive that will
be shared with us in a few years
in 1968 and you know how difficult a
year that was for president johnson he
decided to tape meetings in addition to
taping telephone conversations
and i understand there are about 120
hours of meeting conversations that the
library will get to once it completes
all the telephone tapes
those tapes should i think better than
any record that we have today
reveal
and it'll be difficult i'm sure but the
agony
the difficulties for president johnson
in that year of 1968 and it will be an
irreplaceable record
about the burdens of being president
that's a few years off i believe
okay i think i want to uh repeat uh
uh the director's uh
invitation to come up to the uh
second floor for a champagne reception
um
i have uh
enjoyed this last time with all of you
very much and i'll look forward to
seeing you up there second floor thanks
for being here
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i thought he knew about that
the presidential recordings is published
by w.w norton and company
for more information visit
www.norton.com
[Music]